okay for people joining this live stream
we are talking about machine learning
functionality for
our upcoming version 12.2
and we have a number of updates here
which i need to understand
wait a minute all of them we have worked
in other
meetings yeah i understand this thing
here
is this going in to this version
so i think you'll reduce yes uh already
interesting i don't think so i mean
no uh but array reduce
yes uh zubin you try to improve it so i
did a top-level version
so we need to try to improve it and his
best efforts he couldn't improve it and
he concluded that
it was actually not a bad implementation
even though it's top level
so so i think there's no reason i mean
we put it experimental but there's no
reason not to
not to put it and i think the design is
good and um
yeah okay great
um well that's going to take some
knitting and things
okay let's let's just scan through what
we've got here
ah reply on our livestream is asking
what's the target date for 12-2
well the freeze for the code is today
the rest is your your guess is as good
as ours
i think it's it's it's my impression is
that it's a reasonably solid freeze
roger do you want to comment on that um
i think
most teams it's very solid i think no i
think we will you know
what i can speak for what i see for sure
we it should be
shippable in a month
you know so there's the tail of bugs
now and there are some things that i
don't have insight into you know other
teams so i don't know exactly where
they're coming in
i'm most concerned about some front-end
functionality
okay
and this is when we do this freeze
that's when we get to see it all and
then it's when we start
you know we when we start to get a real
picture of where we have um
and i'm supposed to give a keynote on
tuesday i think
well we'll summarize quite a bit of the
stuff that's in 12 2
plan for 12 2. uh
i don't know that that keynote i would
also
in principle have to cover the 12 1
stuff i think if i do that
those two together it'll be like a seven
hour keynote
good luck with that yeah
we'll see how we handle that um
okay all right
let's see method documentation okay do
we have that now here
um can i see the method documentation
for dimension reduction
you can probably see a few of them yes
like i don't know is a map
or i'm not sure if they've been linked
okay yet so now you're looking at built
okay yes
that's okay it's what are you running
steven is it
it's a 12-2 from today okay great but so
what it should have up here
is a little thing that says list of of
dimensional reduction methods right
they're linked below normally normally
they are linked i don't think the links
have been done yet
normally they will be linked for each of
them here
like we do for classify
do we do that for classify yeah yeah
it's it's really nice when they're
linked because then you go directly to
the right page well no no i agree but i
agree with that but i mean also i i'm
expecting
okay here yeah
you know what when we do this given that
we have these
okay um we should put that up here
list of classify myth
um actually we don't
we don't even have a list we don't have
a separate guide page that has those on
which we probably should have
yeah i see which i see but never mind
i'm i'm
i'm confusing myself i think we should
have a separate guide page
in future that has that has these on it
and has these on it separate guide pages
and then we should do what we do
i mean let me show you what import does
for example
right listing of formats boom there it
is
see what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
by the way on the really topic of having
links
uh net train remember some time ago we
moved all the application examples
to tutorials so now if you look at the
at the
examples and you go to application you
cannot find nothing
and because there's no application but
the tutorials are excellent like if you
look at the tutorial uh
let's have a scheme for putting the
links in there let's say exactly
yeah i wonder what is the traffic on the
tutorials but
i'm scared that it's not really well
known and there's a lot of effort that
is
done and doing good good stuff there
as you see it's pretty thorough well
and the other problem is that that um
i think the people are trained to see
applications here
right so let's say applications and
let's have a scheme
for the um uh if we could get brian
v in this meeting just for a moment we
could probably address this question
right now
i'll try to find him okay
um i think we should just say you open
the applications and it says see
i mean this is you know see neural nets
in the world from language which
shouldn't be really a
tutorial it should be a monograph that's
what these were supposed to be i don't
think that i thought tutorials have been
discontinued as a type
okay all right let's keep going
oh graph and time series i don't know we
could do graphs can we do graphs for
like if i do um uh feature space plot
will it deal with graphs
it should be able to uh wow that's
exciting
they might still be a little bug there
but
okay so where do i see that uh i didn't
put uh i can give you an example if you
want
uh oh i can do it myself i'll do it
myself let me let me do it myself
i'll do it myself um and brian is here
steven hi okay hi there um okay hold on
one second
um i don't know if this is going to work
so good
if that hasn't been communicated to this
team
oh yes yes yes exactly so you have to do
a labeling function right now
it has been communicated to brett and uh
yeah you should you should it's just
about reducing the size of the graph
oh that's beautiful but that's much
better than i expected
now but this is the labeling function
right oh oh yeah
brett has to put in the labeling
function can you make sure that brett
does that
yes yes he's aware either way but it's
just it
was worried that it isn't in place right
now because it just came
right right but but also it shouldn't
have the dots there right he knows that
brett will know that
uh which dots these ones here okay okay
just you know the graph says where it is
basically
okay uh um brian the issue here
is we want to make sure that net train
which currently has no applica okay
first of all why is this called tutorial
uh yeah that's wrong it just needs to
get fixed
well it says overview here well that is
the overview
it's an overview of tech notes
of multiple tech notes uh it could be
one tech note most of these are
this i think this happens to be multiple
tech notes but it there are overviews
that all that are
linked into a single large tech note
that happens okay
so so what we want to do is and i don't
know why that back button goes to the
stupid wrong place down here under
applications
okay we want a type of thing that just
says
you know um c
just say say c neural networks in the
wolfram language
has a link right link sure yeah yeah so
just just get that styled
and um um you know
put that in here and and i think we
should be able to have
both c and c also in other words in this
particular case we're taking all the
applications out of here
and putting them in that place but in
other cases we can say see also
and then have some applications here
does that make sense
yeah yeah that makes sense that's fine
okay great let
let um let etienne know when you have
that in place so you can just add it to
net trade
yeah that's fine i mean there's
certainly it could just be added now
that should just pass through but i
assume you want it to be
styled special i want it to be styled
yeah
yeah okay that's fine i mean i can put
it in just as a stub you want me to put
it in as a stub
you could yeah just under the
application section you could just put a
uh
it could just be an example caption or
something you know some existing style
that uh it should just pass through
um but yeah i mean if you don't have to
worry about it if it's
gonna be a thing to find it too
okay why don't you do it i'll just take
care of it it's fine yep okay
okay um i think that's everything we
needed thanks
oh yeah all right great thanks bye bye
where's the time series stuff in here
um we didn't put an extractor so
i mean we we yeah we named the extract
of a graph graph features
uh we didn't name it for time series uh
maybe we should
uh i mean it was a
yeah we have to see if it's worth
promoting that that much because it was
a bit naive
timothy is improving it right now okay
but i think you should mention that it
works for i mean someplace here
it says
images graphs you know there's also
entity
dates i mean a bunch of
that's at least something are there
other functions that need similar
updates
i think there may be right because then
classify also can do these things
all all machine learning functions can
you take care of that please
yeah okay um
okay calibration control measures
so where do i where do i look here to
see that so so this is something i mean
you can look in classifier measurements
and uh yeah look at documentation
classified measurements actually that's
a lot of things changed there
including the the
the fact that it's a report that is that
is returned now when you do classifier
measurements
instead of the classifier measurement
object i mean still classify measurement
object but it displays as a report
thing that changed as well is that you
can
you know use it without a classifier
and you can see the first first example
is with the classifier
i think the first scope example also i
just i just
decided to change the scope to reflect
so i didn't finish but to reflect the
different type of measures you can do
you know and so if i for example open
decision matrix
so that's something that people have
been asking for a while that you can use
it without a classifier
so the first argument is just the list
of classified data
and the second argument is uh is a real
classes and uh
oh there you go he did that yeah we did
that with roger
and exactly you can see also there's a
little paragraph so it can be a list of
class
can be a list of probabilities
or a list of distribution like a
categorical distribution
which is like the nice
looks good and yeah so it returns this
report
and which is something you agreed on
quite some time ago but
i didn't do it yet
and the calibration well if you go in
scope and you open the calibration
probability calibration
section
you'll see the
reliability reliability diagram
which is basically the the the the
property
that measures that are we capitalizing
these things
i'm not sure not sure let's check
consistency
yeah yeah i'm not sure yeah
a title probably but maybe probably
maybe not uh
yeah i think not the actual names of the
axes
should check that
project by the way what's happening with
the actual development work on time
series
oh well they they they were working on
spatial right so
so we're we're this
is just a bandwidth problem okay
well we should talk about that
separately okay
um okay
but but but we'll do that next you know
there's a long list of things we know
about and this will have some meetings
and so we can sweep up
what are um ambient requests
i really like the spatial statistics
stuff it's really nice good
there but i mean so so
the you know the next thing there is
spatial fields
yes i think we will do time since we
want the time series
we really do upstairs yeah do time
series in between
but we should talk about the bandwidth
situation there too you and i yeah okay
um i think we've got some possible ways
to solve that
okay okay uh
what am i looking at here documentation
yeah nothing much changed uh to the
continuation of some change that were
mean i don't know if you saw that
it's like the updated uh so there was
still some method that we had and
uh yeah i i did see some of this this is
very nice yeah
and we're trying to do the same thing
for for for i mean
we are doing the same thing for
dimension reduction
uh which is a bit more tricky you know
how do you visualize i mean it's
basically feature space plot
so if you load i don't know is a map
maybe
i forgot which one looked nice but um
if you look for the function page i
don't know maybe
or i somehow find one yeah
why is that a function it's not a
function page is it no it's it's a
method
yeah i don't know even how to search for
the method things okay i
think time series data type for this
okay supporting time series and sequence
predict that's really important
okay yeah yeah this one we're going
you should have as one of the basic
examples of something in sequence
something as a time series yeah yeah
we are having a bit of trouble with that
one um
okay mx snap back end update that's a
new version of mxnet
and this is idea
so the build of mxnet is some really
nasty thing
and um it has been done for cpu
and for gpu um release engineering has
trouble to make it work
and honestly i don't know how i don't
know to
like we exchange a few emails
i don't know how to make that work uh
well i mean have you talked to anyone
about it no to one would i talk to uh
uh patrick rice um yeah maybe i should i
should talk to arnold and
i'll take contribution with and the
issue is in video gpus is that right
is there some problem it's it's i don't
know this
it's a complicated thing and they have a
hard time to make a bill that works
and uh
yeah and and and then now they tell us
that it's a bit too late
and oh come on it's not too late
okay so the answer is you have to push
exactly
exactly and if if absolutely necessary
you can get me involved and i'll try and
help understand what to do or we'll get
help from nvidia
yeah i think yeah yeah eventually
eventually it should be as i do this
build
so i mean we have a plan we have we had
a plan
uh to to have new machines and think
that re could have a look on
and you know help us install things but
we would
actually try to do the build and modify
all the flags and do all the things
ourselves
um but but this machine is not only at
this environment it's not set up yet
uh so i think when we have that it
should be smooth because it has been
quite a
you know a painful um
to have this build uh done which i
understand it's they say it's clearly
the more complex library that they they
have
uh yes i i understand but but my point
is
we can absolutely get nvidia to help us
do this if we run into trouble that's
related to building mxnet
if it's building our own software it's
one thing but it's building a freaking
library
it's you know it's a not an issue type
thing
okay um
new icons for netcraft those are icons
for the display of networks is that
correct yeah
yeah yeah um so we have new icon there's
still a little bit of work that is done
on them
uh i think i think it will be i think to
be nice
um yeah there's still some fine-tuning
things to center a little bit
uh so but overall i think it's clean
uh it wasn't again at the end there was
there were some things that didn't
really have icons before
uh let me think
i mean i mean yeah yeah okay there's
been a lot of change like the shape
uh changes like if there is
parameters inside it's a square if
there's no parameter inside so they are
wrong these icons i can see because
i can see a ramp that is a square the
the so i mean if i say net model
some random thing okay i hope it's uh
merged it should be
that is very slow are these in the cdn
are these networks in the cdn that's
something these
content delivery network who is
who is um handling jezebel
okay yep are you could you please check
that
um that's an issue for
i kind of think that is um
ah let me see well actually um
ben h um
it's project managing that i believe
making sure that things so you
understand the issue is whether the cdn
is something
which is a you know global content
delivery network i managed to cdn
stephen i know what what that is now you
know what that is i'm telling etienne oh
okay
right but but the issue is pushing all
the things in the neural net repository
to the cdn
right
because that download speed was
ridiculously slow
okay so what am i supposed to see here
so each time you see a net graph
and so in some you see icons which is
not the case until you click
on is there another graph here
don't find it no there's not a graph
here so
maybe copy an example of netgraph
documentation
or yeah i don't know yeah if you copy
this you'll see that
i mean this one nothing much will change
there's a shape i think that
some will get round
and uh there you go so
you see the red is round now because
there's no parameter in it
you know it bothers me to see pink like
that
i think we should get another kind of
pink yeah
i mean it's already another type kind of
pink than the era
tried something else blue and many
people didn't like it
uh we didn't find the right color uh but
i agree that
i would love to find a better color well
lost function is purple now maybe what
we need to do is just
border these with red and not put them
in not put them in full
pink so to speak to show that they're
not initialized
i also think that uninitialized icon
there is a little bit ugly
yeah yeah the one initialized is great i
like the pastel
this one here yeah yeah this is this
color
and if you initialize on that graph um
let's try to find some others like if
you if you scroll down on that graph
let's see there might be there might be
some uh
well let's find out maybe take a big uh
which one let me find that
but something which has an lstm net
model
i mean the
with the caps net uh caps net will have
a lot of things
yeah well this just had a bug an error
oh my god
i don't believe this yes bill do you see
what it just did
yeah yeah yeah it's just incredible
it's a gremlin do you have multiple
wolfram engines open right now i do not
i do not and and this is a single one
and it's been
i just unbelievable okay okay i will
savat had these gremlins in years past
which this particular gremlin that sets
this particular thing
keeps resetting the setting yep
i had to go into the um
the option inspector to correct it no
we've already done that
multiple way deeper than that yes yeah
no no the fact that it resets this
gremlin has been installed the init file
yeah and and the init file got um
rewritten so something's rewriting so
something's overwriting the init file
yeah with the preference yeah no if it
happens repeatedly then obviously it's
it's it's being
by the way somebody should ask filippo
in solutions who gave me the thing that
almost certainly did this
in more detail what he did okay in
detail what he gave me
philippe okay will do
really annoying okay anyway that's a
that's the thing that's happening here
this is
giving some key value whatever it was
thing
okay so now you can see the one on the
left yeah you can click it the one that
that
are thick which i think is a little bit
too thick the border
uh indicate that there's stuff inside so
it's mean it's not a leaf of the graph
so to speak
of this tree well i like the i like the
dotted lines
indicating that that's what i've
selected that's nice
yeah and so i so if you click the one
there should be something else to click
uh
netmap right oh yeah there's a ramp you
can click the ramp
net ramp that's uh okay
so here if i want to get from the net
graph from this thing i want to get that
image out how do i get that image how do
i get the full publication image type
thing
information and there might be probably
a property
i don't remember exactly but check the
properties
check second argument you do properties
and uh
i think um somebody graphic
maybe yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
it's that yeah
i think we should have a mechanism
yeah nice why did that
maybe there's a plot version
this is um this telegraph
graphic actually well that's a graphic
because we can see from the orange
border
it's not obviously bad but it's slightly
funky um but listen i think we should
expose this more obviously because i
think it's a really nice feature that
you can get these
icons and people won't know you can do
that
so i'm just kind of wondering how we do
that whether we have a little thing at
the bottom here
that is you know a copy graphic or
something
do you see what i'm saying yeah yeah
that sounds like a really good idea to
me because then you can't
avoid it you'll get reminded every time
right or even a mouse over on the
graphic itself
or something and we need a graphical
mechanism to say you can copy the
graphic
yeah and yeah there's a lot of
interactivity already in these things
but why not right
right okay by the way ali on our live
stream is getting concerned that means
we won't be able to use net train with
gpus in 12.2 don't worry we will solve
the problem
yes that's the feature of having these
live streams is that
that the there are there are aspects of
the construction of sausage which seem
quite scary oh yeah this is nothing
we'll yeah we'll get solved the
um
uh okay
uh custom layer now didn't complain
it's compiled layer compiler yeah
compiler yeah yeah it has been
it has been merged uh but it's not
oh no that's not this is uh so so how
are we storing the the the compiled code
um unfortunately right now
it's not stolen in any efficient manner
so so so it will still take time
okay so i am 99 certain you can use this
framework
christopher's to do it did you
investigate yeah
uh not with chris i mean another with
christopher
uh we talked with uh with tom
and there was no i mean a little bit of
i look
no no information it's mateo that has
been dealing with
no no no no no no no no this is another
one of these
you know gotta be solved thing okay so
listen yeah i agree with that one of
these issues with the function
repository right
we have some functions that in fact we
had one that just should have got
submitted in the last couple of days
that uses compiled code right so i'm
insisting that
in the function repository right when
you
we know what what machine type you're on
so we know
what you know dynamic library or
whatever you should be downloading
okay so there is supposed to be some
plumbing to make that work
now the case that you have here where
somebody has stored a compiled layer
i mean i think what we've agreed is that
the compiler will throw things into the
local object store
as a cache yeah i think that's what we
agree i think i think
christopher and i looked at that and i
think the idea is once you've compiled
something
it will crypto hash the thing you
compiled
and uh you know throw a version into the
local object store
and um if you're compiling the same
thing again it will just use the same
compiled code
do you see what i'm saying yeah yeah
okay so
i mean um i don't know who is project
managing that
process of getting um uh
who is who is pm'ing the compiler
project in general
is both you happen to know
uh i think it was andrea but i'll check
okay it may need this particular issue
may need some forcefulness
um it seems to be some level of
confusion about it but the basic point
is
you should be storing in a byte array
the actual compiled code
uh you know on a per platform basis et
cetera et cetera et cetera et cetera
right these layers will not be a lot of
code right
will they will they have lots of weights
in them and things
i think normally they're pretty simple
okay fine yeah yeah then it should be
easy
all right fine okay
let's let's make sure this works okay
it's not going to work to have the
compiled layer be recompiled you know
the thing that i was compiling took 90
seconds to compile
okay it's back in the you know in the
old days before compilers were fast back
in the 19 you know
1970s compilers were slow
and you had to do like two hours to
compile things and so on
okay what's net fraction function layer
since we recently renamed it okay does
it exist
yep i mean yeah if you look for function
layer you should find it
okay so this is using this is the stuff
this is the very
modest set of things that we can do with
that we can sort of compile directly
right yeah
so if i say
how would i first see if i say net oops
function layer isn't isn't showing up as
as working
yeah i think there's been more what is
that what is the message if it doesn't
work
um i don't know i don't know
should be documented in possible issues
presumably yeah
let's let's forget the please thank you
thing
let's just say one or the other
yeah i haven't reviewed all the
all of this yet
it has been quite last minute um oh we
can have the please and thank you i
suppose it's just weird because we don't
do that anywhere else
um i wouldn't have expected mateo to be
the leader of politeness and
and messages it's it's uh it's genome
oh okay the um
okay what's it gonna do though if
there's a function that is not supported
i mean it's just it just says sorry that
function isn't supported
i think so which
yes i don't see any any alternative to
that i mean but maybe we should point
people to compiled layer
in some cases
it's going to be hard to understand what
function layer does versus what compiled
layer does
yeah yeah i mean we kind of explained
that internally it converts to a net
graph
so i think that mechanics clear things
clearer and
actually actually you can see here you
see at the top of future layer you have
the function and then you have the net
and you can click one or the others to
see either the function or the net
um oh i see
yeah so so we always this duality and
it's pretty clear that it's uh
that it's a net as well right
i mean now the representation of this as
a net reminds one of code graphs and
reminds one of the
of the automatic differentiation
discussion that we had
the fact that it's possible to represent
this as a net
i mean i i kind of realized from that
discussion
the key idea just to repeat that for a
second
the key idea is it's kind of like
um sort of
variation at every corner so to speak
you you've got
a you know you've got an evaluation of a
function it goes through many
steps it has there are many you know
there's a hundred variables
and you've got a particular value of
those hundred variables now you want to
do sensitivity analysis basically
with respect to those hundred variables
and
so far as it's a call graph a code graph
it is basically just the chain rule and
basically the variation of the whole
thing
is the variation of every
you know is the result of varying every
uh
okay in to first order i mean this this
is me learning calculus okay
to first order the variation of the
whole thing is just the sum of the
variations at every at every
at every node of the code graph right
so in a sense what that's doing is it's
it's it's making
real the notion that that the
derivative is the first order you know
first i mean that that's a that's a very
straightforward thing for us to imagine
doing
that is we have a function represented
somehow
it is a it's a piece of functional
programming
that has a fixed number of you know you
you can't vary the depth
of the un you know you have to have
something which has a definite
number of unrollings you can't say
there's a parameter
that has you know it goes from five to
six it's incremental everything is
every every parameter that's going to be
varied is a real number
and there better not be any branch cuts
or any other weird stuff going on
right and then what we're saying is
we're just going to take that and
take the symbolic representation of that
and
vary it at every turn so to speak so in
other words what we're saying is
for every function f of x in that thing
we also have
a uh what we might call you know first
order variation of f if this is making
sense
roger are you following this as i think
you were in a very
roundabout way trying to explain the
different automatic differentiation
yes that's what i'm doing i'm trying to
explain it in a way that we can
immediately implement
because what i'm saying is if you have f
of g of h of whatever it is right
you have some complicated function what
i'm saying is
so long as we say that if we say that
first order variation let's say
of f of x right
does something definite that's what we
need for automatic differentiation so so
rob was talking about all these
derivatives and so on i'm just i'm just
saying
that what we need is simply for every
argument
i mean what we need is is something
which is essentially the derivative
except it's a numerical version of that
it's essentially exactly what we have
right now
for derivative we're just writing this
thing out we're going through this whole
thing here
applying the chain rule and doing this
and i don't think we need something
different
i think we need a numerical version of
our current derivative idea
i'm just unconfusing myself i i think
i'm now unconfused here
and i think that the whole thing about
directional adjoint derivatives and so
on
is a different herring
not entirely red but but a herring of a
different color
it's it's um yeah just
projection of jacobian and some
direction and
i know and that's useful yeah as usual
i i realized that but that's this the
ultimate thing you're doing
is you're taking every function and
every variable in every function and
you're just wiggling it a bit
and you're seeing what happens yes
also that's derivative yes also
non-derivative that's right which is
exactly what we call it is derivative
right yes yes no i mean the the thing
that we looked at
it's not for this version but this this
adjoint derivative and directional
derivative
they are needed
partly because you want to be able to
express that
from outside from these parameters i
agree yes i agree
i agree you absolutely need that but the
thing that identifies the thing that
burrows into the expression
i think is just derivative it is no no
it is
it is an ad automatic differentiation is
an
organized way of doing that yeah i
understand but it's yeah right i get it
i've now understood exactly what has to
be done there
right i mean i i'm i'm part of
yeah i mean part of my effort to
understand calculus
is you know because of the
generalization of calculus that we need
for these fractional dimensional spaces
so i'm that's that's my
that's my other use case for this for
understanding this all right
yeah there um
all right cluster dissimilarity loss
layer
uh this is gone this is not um i'm not
going to make it
this is no no it's something that it's
more than a match processing team but
it's working on it but
um jerome is also working with them on
that
it's something to to train feature
extractors
neural network feature extractors and
yeah there's this new type of loss which
is a little bit weird so there will be
some design there
um yeah but not for 12.
placeholder yes yes that's making it
so
very simple layer
what the heck is it
it's it's something it's it's i think we
talked about it already it's when you
import a network
and there's let's say a layer that
cannot be
converted it will replace it in terms of
failing it will replace it with a
placeholder layer
that then you can go by hand and maybe
replace with the google okay but what
you want to do if you do the import
you absolutely need in that placeholder
layer in the association you need
whatever the text was of the layer you
couldn't import
right yeah yeah that's uh yeah
so um
for the onyx importer to yeah what are
you going to call that
i mean so in other words
i mean what you've got to explain is
that this placeholder layer
i don't remember i think you might do
that already i'm not sure well it
doesn't say it does that
suppose the following options i mean it
doesn't say it does that
um
i think let's see
um what should it be called
i mean we we have that issue in the
front end
we put into tagging rules things that
come from importing other formats where
we can't
you know where it's a meaningless piece
of information
now when we get something in is it going
to be a piece of text or is it going to
be more structured
i mean it might also be conceptual
contextualized
right when it comes in here
do you understand what i'm saying no
what i mean by that is the onyx import
of some layer right what is it which
came in
is it you know i have no idea what
native onyx looks like
do you see what i'm saying when we
import it's going to be one of our
layers there's no representation of onyx
but what i'm saying is exactly this you
said it's a layer we can't import
right yes yes exactly okay so what i'm
saying is
that corresponded to 10 lines of onyx
code whatever that looks like oh i see
yeah yeah okay
what i'm saying is put those ten lines
of onyx code
into the association in placeholder
layer
so when you're looking at the thing it's
like oh okay now i see what that is
let me go and untangle it yeah yeah but
isn't that just
pick a standard key where it goes yes
but what i'm asking is
i don't know what onyx looks like and i
do not know whether it is textual in
that sense
or whether the thing whether there are
whether you need a whole
like like let's imagine that onyx was
like exif data
from an image right yeah you could have
the xf string
but it'd be more useful to break it out
into some pieces
see what i'm saying yeah so that's
all i'm asking is what's the natural way
of importing i think
we need to then look into that but like
exit we can't make
everything we did we did
for the you know i know that are numbers
we make
numbers yeah we did obvious things with
exif but people
except you know some random manufacturer
of moon cameras or something
can add all kinds of other junk to the
exif data and they have
yeah yeah right which which we can't
import it's fine we just
it's just a key value thing for us right
but in this case
what i want to know is is something like
um
uh what do we want to call this
um i think we should call it like
imported string
okay in the association
does that make sense
that ian yeah yeah yeah
okay but but as i say i if if there is
more
structure let's preserve that structure
yes the importer knows
that for example this is in this
environment with these variables blah
blah blah blah
let's preserve whatever structure the
importer had and
you know put that into the internals of
the importer
into this layer but something it's
probably been passed already a little
bit
at the point where it cannot convert
well right that's my point
so i'm saying preserve paused
information but i would say that
that that the the bottom line nothing
else can be done we call it imported
string
you know imported code or yeah imported
code is fine
who knows what it is yes fine yeah right
okay
and this should explain
what does this layer do if you just run
a neural net this layer is a no-op
is that correct yes i don't think it
will return anything
that's two different statements a no up
is not the same as saying it returns
nothing
what i was assuming it would do is pass
through the data
that its output is equal to its input or
does it have separately defined input
and output ports
what does it do does it generate an
error or what does it do
i think so yes i think it will uh narrow
i i i
yeah i don't know actually okay fine i
mean the point is not to use it the
point is to replace i i'm aware of that
i'm just asking what it actually does if
by some
okay so look to my mind right there are
two things so we can have a network
that's uninitialized and it says oh i'm
uninitialized right and they can't do
anything useful you you
you i don't what does it do when you
when you apply an uninitialized network
to um data what will
what will come out does it does it
allows messages
okay fine i know okay fine so this is
the same thing
so if there is a network that contains
placeholder layers
it needs to say i mean
are we sure it should be called
placeholder layer rather than undefined
layer
rather than what sorry undefined layer
undefined layer
yeah we didn't come up with that name
undefined layer i think that's a better
name for it
i mean it's really an error condition
basically
yeah i mean undefined seems fine to me
okay then what we should do is is is
state
that there is an undefined layer if you
have a network
and you're you know looking at it and
you see the visual thing it should say
uh you know with a little red thing two
undefined layers or something
yeah yeah i guess the placeholder name
might be good when you are actually
using to construct networks sometimes
you're like
okay i know that this part of the
network will take this amount of input
the smart output so i'm just put
placeholder
then i can construct things around it
and then i will replace it
you know i mean we can imagine doing
things like that i don't know how much
it's going to be used
in that sense it's really a placeholder
uh
but undefined i don't know
i i don't know that's the team i i
i tend to think that but i it is
important that we
tag it to say even at the top level
there are three
defined layers in this network right so
you don't try running it and things
does that make sense yeah yeah
okay
oh boy
and this is called a random array layer
rather than a random variate layer
why
ah because it returned an array
and we had all this
xx array layer but but but honestly
i mean i think we
i think random actually yeah maybe one
right is good huh
uh i don't know i think random array
layer is
okay if it's a if it has the feature
by the way if you say round and round
open close surely it should just
generate a uniform distribution from
zero to one
if you don't specify any distribution
it's uniform by default
yeah okay yeah seems sensible
yeah yeah yeah i agree um
i think random ray is better than ryan
barrett i think random versus too weird
okay did this get horrifying this
threading layer thing
well the the one addition in this
broadcast
thing that we really need
and uh it's done with uh with a number
that specifies yeah well you know
as far as i'm concerned these functions
are still basically the machine code of
machine learning
yeah it's fine
yeah i mean hopefully people will
you know function layer will be very
successful and its successor will uh
right um okay
onyx export let's talk about that do we
have workflows written to describe how
you do uh export from onyx to core ml
and all this kind of stuff that's
it's it's been done right now so joffrey
is working
on training actually
getting some data training exporting to
one x converting to core ml and make it
run on his iphone
and uh he actually managed to do it
so um so so he has a network that is
that is uh running on his iphone
and he's now writing a blog about it
cool
okay so one place where that's important
is the front end team
is working on this uh some of this ocr
stuff
you're aware of this right yes etienne
responded to the threat to
when i said onyx is the method okay all
right but did they seem to accept that
or were they still
saying they're trying to use random c
code from somewhere
i'm not sure that there is a plan to use
a network i think it was just
one of the possibilities so
right but that was relevant only i
understand but the absolute thing that
they cannot do is start writing custom c
code to run on a random
phone to do this particular thing would
be better off
using i think it would be good to follow
up who who was doing there
was it joffrey did you say no no well
yeah joffrey should talk to
zitman i guess who's doing the um yeah
that would be really good
case to see fine
but my point of view is this and it kind
of follows your analysis of neural nets
roger
this is basically you know we now have a
hammer
even though there might be classical
image processing algorithms that could
be used for this purpose
you know because we now have a hammer
let's use it so to speak
yeah right but in particular and i also
think that this is super useful this
for many people including our own teams
to get the artifacts out
and be able to use them right but that
that means so okay so joffrey is going
to write
the um the uh uh workflow documentation
is that correct
at end yes yes yes exactly i want yeah
blog post and then whatever
workflow documentation i said something
specific right
you know our workflows you know what i'm
talking about right
i i haven't no no okay
oh we can talk about that yeah
yeah i think they don't think see this
see all these
see all these things down here deploying
to web and mobile wouldn't it be nice to
have something here
that says you know set up a repeated use
form page
right well that's one thing but um you
know this is
deploy to a phone deploying on that to a
phone
i think that makes complete sense that
that does it i mean
i didn't mind to do some sort of
tutorials and everything we can do in
documentation about it
right but this is the this is the type
of actually
actually at the end so under under o for
the uh the docutools palette
there is workflow tagging and there are
if you ask on t new docs they will point
you to the videos
that explain it okay right the whole
point about workflow documentation
is it's for documenting your path
through the jungle
yeah yeah okay because in other words
these things
are not know
this here you see this this has things
like you know copy and address of a
hyperlink
and it's showing stuff which is you know
which is this is the jungle
right that that is perfect for the oh
next to cornmeal thing
yes yes so we wrote a ton of these for
instance for the
the unity link and others that that also
crosses
platforms if you like right
this is the only way to do it i mean
there's a different style of
documentation from our usual
documentation
and it's what we need so what are the
other targets for the onyx export
maybe something for android i don't know
i think we should look into
i mean we should follow up with the onyx
organization identify as
their partner organizations and use
cases which means that all of those
should be open
yeah that's right that's a good thing to
do
[Music]
because in effect there are tons of
accelerators particularly for inference
um that are being you know there's about
30 chip
startup companies for instance they
better accept optics
or a big fraction of them do right so
those are companies we should buy
contact
fine that's part of the developer
relations story
okay um
let's see uh by the way there's some
comments on our live stream here
ali is saying cuda function load seems
to be not working in twelve one one
even though machine learning on gpus
works in windows 10
although the cuda functional load works
in 12.0
is there some packet installation
problem for 121.1 i don't think anybody
here knows but let's go no i think we
need someone that's
like sqa would know probably if there
was such a known problem
k isabelle can you clip that out and ask
them yes of course
uh ic is asking is there a way to get a
list of all tutorials in the
documentation
that's a good suggestion
there isn't right we used to have
some kind of table of contents but right
well the reason we don't have it is
because it's rather inconsistent
but i agree that that there should be a
place where there is simply a listing
as a matter of fact we're starting to
invest in tutorials again
and write new ones uh in a bigger way
yes well i mean the problem is for many
years every tutorial was a
was a a deconstructed version of the you
know my
you know original mathematica book yeah
exactly um
and we also had the impression the
feedback that i felt we got from users
was that
nobody wanted to read it and they wanted
to see sort of the immediate examples
was the big push
right but now we got to tie the story
together which also some
after well pointed out to us and so
that's well i think the point is that
these sub-systems that we have what
happened is
originally the whole system was small
enough that it could be described in a
600-page book
then it became much bigger than
individual subsystems get to the point
where they are describable in 200 page
books
and that's what we need yep
and yes that's a good suggestion and can
we can yes well can you add that
to the um yes uh
new docs documentation reviews
yep that's a uh
brady production um
machine learning on gpus
oh boy version 11 3 does not work with
the nvidia touring architecture gpu
since it was compiled with cuda toolkit
9.
does that mean we need to run 11.3 on
machines with the previous generation
cards for the indefinite future
nobody here knows the answer i'm also
passing that to you to qa
okay um okay a question from nick here
any probabilistic layers for
distributions
and things like kl divergence
or cartoon low low whatever that was the
the um
uh is that the ica thing okay anybody
know what that means
well it was it was sort of um
similarities for for distributions right
yes and uh but i'm not
sure what it means but probabilistic
oh boy we have four separate people on
our live stream saying
uh uh emphasizing how much they like
tutorials
good okay good well there's more coming
there's quite a few
under development and uh push on live
stream is saying video tutorials pl
well now what do you mean by video
tutorials now let's let's understand
what that means
do you mean tutorials that are videos or
do you mean tutorials about our video
functionality
we need to know the answer that um well
there is a tutorial a small tutorial
about video
about the video functionality okay and
we have started to do
i think that with this something
requires more discussion internally but
if you
you know on the live stream if people
have opinions
of how to do maybe a short one minute
intro to functions
video introductions to functions as an
alternative for ref pages
yeah do people want that we would love
to know that because we could easily do
it
we could have we could have a developer
you have one of these things that like
you know the director of a movie saying
hello at the beginning of the movie type
thing we can have the developers of
functions
kind of give their one minute summary of
the function
or is that too scary
we can include include functions that
are very old but the developers
you know developed it 30 years ago and
things um
anyway a question here from ethan will
gpt-2 and
bert variants be trainable in 12-2
i thought we did have trainability for
some of those things
did it say 10-2 12-2
did i say i maybe said 10-2 but he said
12-2
okay okay i didn't know that we could
not train them because when we have the
models so
we should be able to train them yeah i
don't see why
okay even gpt2 is pretty big right
i mean it's not like gpt3 but it is yeah
there's few versions
yeah there's some versions that are
smaller than others
okay um right johnny here on the live
stream is saying
will gpt 3 work with uh
maya and and and often language but
the art gt3 is not as impressive as one
might think
actually i i realize yes it's the
tokenizer
that is that is not um
that is not trainable it's the this bp
tokenizer
and for the next version you'll be able
to train your bp tokenizer
so i guess twelve two answer no no
unfortunately not
okay uh yeah we didn't manage to put
that in but
for the next one it's definitely on the
on the list and it's gonna get done
um i'm unfortunately gonna have to run
i'm already in deep
trouble well okay so we need to okay
all right but you guys can continue if
you want i can continue for a little
while yes
okay um okay see you roger
right um okay
pusher is saying means tutorials that
are videos and brian is suggesting
why don't the documentation pages link
to videos that have been made at our
various conferences which is a very
sensible idea
i i have no idea why we are not doing
that
isabella another one for you sure
you have a good idea the i mean
you know the effort to edit those or
even to re-record some of those
um um
and uh if you remember those live
streams that were done for
12 12 and um
something yes absolutely those have
those those were also meant to be
linked up um from the documentation
i will follow up on who's who's working
on that that process
i would have thought it was the video
team because i think that probably
requires quite a bit of
cutting up of the videos
okay let's take a look at array reduce
um
and also all right
i want to tag it as experimental
yeah i think that's uh
i think that's good
you don't have any seals though here
somebody wants to look at apply
yeah um flatten
what else does this and and look
interestingly that's how i should have
printed it to you in the beginning
integrate it's a little bit remote
but it's kind of the same design you
tell the variable that you want to
integrate over
and error it uses the same thing like
actually already use of total
is kind of the this like what i'm sorry
integrate
integrate i'm going to put some i'm not
gonna put integrate
it's too weird to say integrate some can
you some of uh
yeah i guess yes you can absolutely can
yes
yeah yeah so i guess yeah all right now
what about other
um i mean there's uh yeah transpose
um is transpose relevant
yeah transpose is wrong it allows you to
pull things up to the top
yeah yeah i mean flatten those as well
flatten is more generic actually
um i mean and then there's like i don't
know
just even map
um i should probably put i think apply
is more relevant isn't it
because a fly actually does something to
a layer
uh i don't know um
well okay but it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't go inside the head
or reduce f is given a list of stuff you
know like the head is not
going away well fair enough um
is map at relevant not really
all right let me consult my elephant
here to find out where we've put
array flatten
okay rearranging and restructuring lists
oh yeah are we reshaped like do we have
things like that
we do have a ray reshape but we don't
have it listed here
then that's from
you probably should probably link it as
well
where should we link that at the end
you're gonna see at the end yeah yeah
it's not that
relevant but it's kind of you know
changing dimensions
right okay so then here
um
wow what the heck is that pivot
look at that what do you know
level end because the first level it was
my transpose uh
it was an arrow well look at this
where was this from
and what is a civil uh
lease and second argument
so that the family of support becomes
the first level
that's that's the priorities isn't it
it's one part and it's actually kind of
the inverse like it's
put things at the last level okay you
better look at this
take a look at this but this should be
yeah
this can be done i i think this can be
included to transpose
okay well so where should we put
um
okay are we reduce um
should it go under transpose here should
it go
i know where do we put the map and and
things like that
okay well this is rearranging and
restructuring this yeah
i mean it's user function so i don't
know
still okay
maybe the first the first one with the
flatten
and partition continents
obvious is too generic this i don't know
well okay so i'm gonna put it in here um
no it doesn't shook me
reduce
say dimension dimension or dimensions of
an array
by applying a function
reduce the dimension
okay
all right now on this page we also see
some other things here so
array reshape definitely needs to
talk about array reduce
probably before fold
we flatten let's pick a better reduce
before exactly yeah
put it there too it is amazing how easy
it is to agree on where these all know
what the orderings should be
i thought it would be very difficult um
okay flatten at
i don't think so
um
okay needs transpose somewhere point to
array
um wow
towards the end now honestly i would put
the end out
yeah okay wonder why we don't have a ray
reshape in here i think we should
okay
um
[Music]
where else should this go
okay let's go and find other pages
um
okay put it in those ones do i put in an
array flatten
i think so
i think it goes there
i think
no maybe not maybe it goes at the end
i wonder what substitution system
why it's there yeah i don't know the
connection oh the reason is if you do
two-dimensional
substitution systems it's just it's it's
um
what it's doing is it's it's a ray
flattening at every stage
okay
um
i think it goes at most at the very end
yeah yeah yeah i have to integrate for
sure
um see the uh
off the table i think well
yeah yeah yeah summon table like
actually would i put tables
further up right
something is kind of the
i like it at the end because you notice
it there
it's kind of a different type of
operation
okay let's go back to the elephant
[Music]
um
very reduced definitely goes in tensors
um does it go in structural matrices and
convolution kernels no it does not
handling arrays of data i think it does
go in that
[Music]
um
applying functions to lists most
definitely goes in that
yep okay i'm going to put it in here
okay applying functions to lists so now
multi-element mapping i think it needs
its own
section doesn't it
um what is
array reduction and then we say
um reduce an array
by applying a function
along a certain axis on a certain
dimension at a certain dimension
at a certain level i i i avoid speaking
i'm just saying we should decide i avoid
talking about level because
level kind of involve you know the
expression and everything that is below
okay so reduce
okay by applying a function at a certain
dimension well
i use that in the old documentation but
i don't know what do you what do you say
exactly in the document
i say dimension i mean you can look it's
just behind
um
yeah reduce dimension the dimension of
an array
no
sometimes i say applying f to the vector
along the
dimension okay by applying a function
along a certain dimension
which when you visualize the the array
you know geometrically makes complete
sense
i think we can say a certain dimension
it's the most common case
yeah yeah
yeah i like it okay now
here yeah we put it in there
okay tensors
okay so it goes in this section here
right yeah
i think it just goes at the end of that
section
i mean yeah you know definitely
okay um
what do we say reduce
by
summing by applying
a function a certain index
what is it what's the right term it's
it's transpose say
and this is so okay well but
applying by applying a function
to a certain indices that specified
indices
what do you call the the slots in a
tensor team you knew
what do you call the new in that
you're asking the wrong physicist
[Music]
um
well we have to ask jose to certain
indices or something
yes well could you just see this is a
two-minute
one-minute jose question yeah
meanwhile there's a bunch of comments on
uh for people on a live stream
okay ethan is saying
please add a concept of a detect
function there's no way to
to train detectors
detect for images okay i mean detection
is a type of machine learning problem
not doable
by classify and predict
[Music]
so i think it's a function called detect
yeah we we thought a little bit about
things like that yeah
um well what would be the idea the idea
i mean we have anomaly detect
right uh yeah but that's that's
different so
so it means function that finds subset
in examples such as image cases
that finds you know detect some object
that we could generalize to
you know also to sound to extract some
part in the sound or extract some part
in time series or extract
so wait wait wait so so you're saying
what this would be
is oh i see so this is yeah this we have
wanted this
this is exactly the operation that i've
talked about forever with like find the
dogs in the image type thing it's image
cases basically yeah yeah yeah
and then so the general case is is
detect cases
basically
yeah yeah it's a good suggestion i mean
it has been on our list for some time
but i like the name detect cases
and yeah it would this person would want
something to
that we can train certain detectors
right uh yeah this is all
a class of of these things and including
anomalies for time series you know
we're a bit like the peak detect type
thing but
more more general for anomalies
design wise they're always a bit more
tricky
i think there's also a way to try i hey
listen look
let's just let's just put them put that
that is
you know that has been from two three
years ago that was one of the super
function goals that we had
we wanted to do trainable image cases we
haven't managed to do that
um but this is definitely a an important
future thing
okay can you make sure that's added to
the sort of super functions list
yeah yeah yeah um
okay and let's see we do have did we
manage to get jose here by a chance no
it doesn't look
no not yet i'm still trying so meanwhile
um
um comments about
the ali's questions about
um
um various kinds of hardware gpu stuff
says that somebody i don't even know
who's responding to this says they're
two different issues cuda link and
neural networks they have
separate implementations and separate
code packets okay cuda
function load can fail for various
reasons eg compiler installations
but that should have no effect on
machine learning
net train will have gpu support in 12 2
oh goodness sake although there's an
uncertainty in mac os due to the apple
nvidia problem over
cuda resulting in no mac os drivers for
cuda for several years
um uh
okay so the comments about touring cards
are too recent and not supported in 11.3
so upgrade good thing and it turns out
that this person
is at the most current version anyways
um so we're suggesting
that he contact support okay all right
so there's some other problem
okay jose is here um jose we have a
really simple question for you
the array reduced function how would you
describe that for a tensor
how would i describe that it's saying
reduce by applying a function to
but you don't say to certain indices
what do you call the slots in a tensor
you know well
in in the western language i usually
refer to arrays and levels
if i'm talking about tensors like in a
geometric
way like i would do in general
relativity i usually use
slots or indices to me the this
the tensor has slots and what they put
in the slots are the indices
no no i agree i agree so this is a page
about tensors there's a guide page about
tensors and we're adding array reduce
along with generalized trace and other
such things
reduce along any dimension with any
function
is that a reasonable thing to say along
with dot product generalized inner
product generalized outer products and
so on
unfortunately dimension isn't the right
word really
i i think level would be more
appropriate here
level but but no but that's that's using
our representation of tensors and
etienne has wanted to avoid level
because he thinks it involves subtrees
this is really the index right i mean
it's our alphabetic gamma delta
and this is saying take the index gamma
and sum over all you know it's like a
one-legged einstein summation convention
isn't that correct yes but if if i
remember correctly
array reuse can handle several of these
indices at the same time right
it can it's a bit like flutter in that
sense
yes but does it always apply the same
function to all
all the different index levels
at in say again
combining all dimensions nij to make a
dimension and i
so it's a it doesn't have the
possibility of having multiple different
functions
to apply to different levels no
no it's one function one function
and it's um okay so so i'm i'm going to
come back to my question jose
i mean you say if we want to describe
this purely in terms of tensors
geometric tensor type stuff
right and you are describing our
alphabetic gamma what is gamma what kind
of a thing is gamma in in the in the
tensor language i would use the word
index okay but but can you fit it into
the sentence that i'm writing
reduce along any index with any function
well you could use tensor index to be
specific
so what could i say reduce a tensor
index
reduce along any tensor index
across tensor indices no it's not we
don't want to say across
um
actually you know what we could just say
reduce any tensor index with any
function
yes that makes sense yeah or you could
say reduce
any tensor indices because it can
it can be one or more
with a function all right
okay okay that's good maybe with a
function because any function is a bit
weird because it has to be a function
that reduces right
like just be a total mean or something i
mean it could be something else but it
doesn't
really really and the main use case
is this sort of functions
let's just say that it's pretty obvious
what that means
all right i agree with you that a is
better than any
so what do we do
we don't even mention flatten on the
page for tensors because it's a really
weird operation
right right so but flattened uses the
the level notation it does but it's
doing something very different
i mean no it isn't doing something
different it's just that for this page
this is specifically a page about
tensors right
so that's why i'm using tensor language
here
and in the work in the world of
flattening tensors right which is a
completely
operation you absolutely do not do in
general relativity right
to flatten operations insane in general
relativity
if i'm yes like i'm not sure that
reduction is much better in that sense
so this this reduction to me feels
the category of i mean it doesn't it
doesn't combine
uh you know apples and carrots
no it's jose it's it's one-legged
einstein summation convention
right it's just you know the einstein
summation convention usually is two
indices
which are essentially dotting together
this is saying just
take one index and reduce along it
it's not such a crazy operation and i
think in in
isn't it equivalent if you were to take
this for two indices
i think it will be equivalent to the
summation convention
if i'm not mistaken
no i actually it would be no it isn't
quite equivalent because in the
summation convention
you're taking in this thing you're
taking the whole bag of things
right if you use mean on say
a two a level two slice
that's not the soil operation
yeah no okay
which sorry the last definition
in the box
so this ability of manipulating multiple
indices at the same time yeah that's the
only thing
yeah that that i only associate with
with flutter okay just for your
entertainment for your physics
entertainment okay
one of the new things in our whole uh
uh you know way of
of of um you know deriving quantum
mechanics
is the absolutely bonkers thing that
what seems to happen is that
these quantum phases basically
uh come about from
um space filling curves applied to
bronchial space that is you have a
two-dimensional thing in branches
the two-dimensional thing which would
naturally be two-dimensional
and literally the quantum phase comes
about by actually having a weird
space-filling curve
that that walks around the thing not
totally bizarre
and it looks like this i mean anyway
still
still some things to be understood about
it but it's it's um
uh very weird i've never seen anything
like that it's a place where you
actually have a flatten
that's coming out from this weird higher
category stuff
is essentially implementing a flatten i
see
just really weird um okay that was what
we wanted i think
for this um uh
anything else for jose here
oh okay thanks jose okay thank you bye
bye um
okay
um
[Music]
okay awesome to be able to export a
standalone dll or even c code for a
trained classifier that's exactly what
we should have from onyx export
um
uh sl8 is saying video tutorials will be
function video sure be okay first and
foremost
oh boy this is talking about the
independence of products
in our product line that's a different
that's something that's in jezebel's
area um
well it's a comment an interesting
comment from sla which you can look at
as well
yep um
right okay last items here uh from atian
oops i need to do i need to save array
reduce i don't think i touched array
reduce i don't want to save it
oh did i wait wait wait yes i did i did
i put in it's it's the also so i didn't
yeah
of course um
what what do you think of the graphic
i don't think it's bad i don't think
it's better
i kind of hack it up today and uh
right you like these annotations of
arrays and i i don't think yeah yeah
um
otherwise i think we so
okay let's take a look um
the search thing okay so what's
happening here with with the search
system this is just the ongoing project
of improving the search
which go incrementally there haven't
been any
revolution wait a minute did the entity
thing get done did the war from alpha
search thing get done
oh yeah at least i'm not sure these okay
because that that has to do with it
so i think so okay so can i see it
someplace
yeah um let's say
chicago here oh
no i'm not seeing it here yeah
right so that's what i want to see is i
want to see the the entity search come
up at the top
right which we can do from the wolfman
alpha query recognizer
i thought it was uh okay well maybe it's
just not available on the and
yet in product here because that's a
complicated thing it's got to have both
um uh
okay
um
okay
um right well it's just a random thing
i don't want to re-document it but i did
something to convert uh
you know a fitted model like the classic
statistical model
to predictor function yes
so if you do predict or a fitted model
it will convert it to a
to a predictor function which has been
asked by people but actually the reason
they asked was for
to use in classifier measurements sorry
predictor measurements
but since now you can use prictor
measurements without a predictor
that that useful but i think it might be
good that we start connecting the
statistics in the machine
absolutely look what we really need to
do is to pass
which i think you and your team should
do on the statistics functionality to
modernize it
given what we now know about machine
learning both in terms of the input
parsing
and some of the presentation and so on i
don't think it's very difficult
i think it's it's like um it's like
you know you know now that you can fly a
starship you can fly a helicopter type
thing
you know that stuff is 1930s type
technology
yeah yeah i mean there's some
differences
well but i think i think a lot of those
things like you know all the indicators
and things like that
we now have more sophisticated versions
of stuff like that
and we have more sophisticated
frameworks for displaying
you know complicated uh diagnostic
information from doing
you know analysis all right so i don't
really
this is not really a review of the
search stuff since we don't have the
relevant people here
so i mean that's a separate thing to
review that and understand what's
happening with it
and and the one thing that i thought we
were going to see didn't work
so not encouraging
uh all right anything else i mean i can
tell you in terms of
of results um like like
i mean on our benchmark things things
are quite uh improving um still
still some road to to to travel but
okay i think it's it's not intensively
better the
the search okay well fine but i mean i
think you know there's a certain amount
of stuff to do with
um being able to extract the information
from the original documents
and then there's the question of how the
ranking works are we yet using our
machine learning stuff in the ranking
um uh pipeline
not no not directly we are using a
data set to to improve the parameters
that are in leucine uh my my strategy
was always to to push lucien kind of to
the end and i kind of
i think there's still a little bit of
margin we can get
and when we're stuck try to get the the
bigger guns
uh by we're just changing the mobile and
having a more complex model
and uh potentially a better data set as
well we start seeing the limit of our
data set
but of course everything that i said by
hand is is a kind of uh
but we're getting better like like we
create small data set by hand like you
know 100 queries here 100 queries there
who is who is ranking them uh it's uh
it's nicolas
it's nicolas and uh usually it's okay
but i mean the problem is what happened
previously
no no we had a kind of ranking panel of
a bunch of people
and what ended up happening is i mean
this is something that
uh maybe some
uh maybe even at the conference this
coming week we could we could
ask some people to rank some stuff why
don't we find that out find out whether
that's possible
if we've got some ranking tests because
the problem was
when we asked for rankings even from
internal people people
disagreed on what the rankings should be
dramatically
yeah i mean i think i don't know how
what set up the problem but you know the
10th position we don't care like
if you simplify it like just give your
top three i'm not oh i agree
between people well yes and no what we
found is that
the people with different levels of
sophistication
were picking out different things to be
at the top yeah
well yeah we can be good even even
they're different it's still that i said
that would be much better than what we
have
well we have such a data set we we made
it like three years ago or something we
had a bunch of people do that
for many queries so if you don't have
that data set you should have it
yeah also arnold was leading this effort
to to to to obtain a guess
from the cloud oh no from the product
from the products like that that users
could could kind of uh
opt in to to have data about what they
click
on the on the documentation search and
then we can
you know infer that if they click
position six then
it should be bumped up yep and um
because that would be good yep
all right uh
oh yeah he's he's some
ali is commenting once
pointers to scientific literature for
which algorithms are being used
in um for particular functions
oh yeah that's a complicated story i
mean
it's a good topic to discuss uh
it's just complicated because it's often
combinations of things
and it's our own version of them and
this and that and the other
um
yeah we should we should have that not
not for today
but that's a a discussion um
and again i i think the fraction of
people who care is much smaller than you
think
most people just see i mean one cares
when an algorithm
is rather heuristic you know to quote
how we compute a bessel function it's
like well it'd be nice to give
credit to the you know person who
figured out the algorithm it's probably
somebody internal to our company in this
case
um but it's not really necessary because
unless we messed it up
it's just the value of a vessel function
but in other cases where it's much more
arbitrary like
a friend of mine for a while was the
most cited scientific author
because he was one of the authors of the
blast
standard for sequence alignment which
has
essentially has a heuristic in it and so
it's not like if it was like a precise
sequence alignment which is what it was
supposed to be
but it had to have a heuristic and so
that meant it had to be quoted
everywhere because
that was the definition of what um
you know uh of what which sequence
alignment you were using
anyway can we in fact that that is a
good topic
for um uh probably the
documentation meeting maybe isabelle
could get that
i got it yeah okay all right
okay thanks everybody thanks to folks
some
who've been following us on the live
stream i think we have several more live
streams tomorrow i can see that
as we approach this um release the
intensity gets higher
and of course there's the technology
conference next week which um
uh particularly since everything is
remote i um
hope lots of people will be able to come
to um
all right see you later see you at here
and it's probably late oh now now that
you've moved
to the that side of the world it's now
late for you
yeah oh well okay that's okay
all right